1994 les gazelles josé les rock machine
s'engage dans une guerre ouverte
on a vu ma nation veut un climat de
violence au québec et déstabilisation de
la paix sociale les attentats à la bombe
les meurtres commandées ont fait une
trentaine de victimes
les corps policiers en ont plein les
bras on ne se sentait pas vraiment
outillés pour être capable de faire
lutter contre ces deux clubs si on veut
les votre machine et les hells angels
ça devenait très difficile parce qu'il y
avait comme paul des squales attitré les
gouvernements ne s'intéressaient pas
tellement à cette guerre là parce que ça
se passait surtout entre les principaux
belligérants
montréal un enfant repose entre la vie
et la mort après l'explosion d'une bombe
neuf ou 1995 le conflit fait une
première victime innocente
un enfant de 11 daniel desrochers qui
rentrait chez lui à pied sur la rue adam
a reçu en plein visage un morceau de
carrosserie ça c'est un événement qui a
saisi la population et nous aussi on
était traumatisée lopavent des
explosions d'une telle ampleur la
négligence si on veut ne pas se soucier
de ce qui pouvait arriver au dos
la mort de daniel desrochers devient le
point tournant dans la lutte contre les
motards sa mère monte au front
josé est mme desrochers lance une
pétition adressée à ottawa ça continue
de plus belle il faut absolument faire
réagir le gouvernement à notre faveur
d'obtenir pour la loire une première
mouture entre en vigueur en 1997
de son côté québec crée l'escouade
carcajou un regroupement de corps
policiers municipaux de la sûreté du
québec et de la grc de mettre toutes nos
sources d'information en commun donc
c'était une arme très efficace contre
les moteurs les angels sont déstabilisés
avec l'opération printemps 2001 qui mène
à l'arrestation de 130 de leurs membres
ou associés en 2009
l'arrestation de 156 personnes devaient
être le coup de grâce
l'opération sharqc stèle des objectifs
quasiment d'anéantir les hells angels
sauf que ça fait chou blanc devant les
tribunaux les ailes actuellement au le
monopole total dans la province de
québec aux nouveaux besoins est une
partie des maritimes dont 15 seront
nulles m'a inquiété les traces de
l'attentât qui a coûté la vie à daniel
desrochers ont disparu depuis longtemps
il ne reste que son nom gravé au sol
dans la cour d'école qui l'a fréquenté
ici valérie michaela bayne radio canada
montréal